哇 今天台灣股市上漲了214.
季線保運站成功
可是4萬點會不會再跌破
還有莫德納爆漲176%
你到頭夥張176%
等於100塊馬上漲到276塊
欸 市值增加一兆
一天增加一兆
AI下個關鍵市場
是不是則則說的
產生不老已經不是夢了
講產生不老有點誇張
查命百歲真的已經可能不是夢了
我都有獨家預告
你會發現我像預約家不像分析師
真的沒辦法胡扯
第三個美國緊急回購美債
資金會回流股是嗎
今天這三大重點
我一次讓我一次愛個夠
讓我一次講個夠
大家好 我是某個投顧的投資長郭總分析師
也是全台灣粉絲人數最多的
波轉投射 波轉分醫師
可是我覺得我講的
有時候 與其說我當分醫師
我不喜歡 我不如我當預言家
我比較喜歡當預言家
分醫師實在是我覺得不難擔 好不好 不難擔
不知道跟大家胡扯
昨天有沒有說結算建成責 今天拉起來對不對
我們說很多股票說不要去追高 你看
那精彩很像神經病
不要去追高有沒有
哇 拉展庭又殺下去了
股票這樣子 跌停的時候又拉起來
現在GoPro好像很難做,也不會難做啊
為什麼不會難做?你看譬如說2344
華版店昨天不行就拉起來了
當然今天有一個族群特別落實
國際怎麼看?我看五百多塊
閉眼睛買吧,AI就是趨勢
這時候實話實說
我很多東西我都預告在前面
為什麼說實話實說?
你們看一個股票就好了
建議單股票大跌為什麼開高走低
很簡單嘛你們看這新聞就知道了嘛
來來來
這邊
超微奪單Google啦
你知道
聯發科警戒
是不是
超微是就蘇之鋒MD
蘇奪單什麼TPU晶片你知道
超微奪單Google
連發科警戒,你看對不對?
連發科聽到這個消息被人家奪單了啦,
來我們來看一下,我們看一下所謂的外資啦,
看一下,看一下,賣隔離啦,賣給你啦,
他不買自己買啦,他不買啊,叫你買啦,
不買我沒有證據啦,可是叫你買啦,來,
連發科評價麥格里罕3萬元給予優於大盤
他把2028年ASK營收達400億美元
我那時候一直罵
有沒有 你會發現我認識
我不是分析師 我是預言家
這樣講話很誇張
可是我喜歡邏輯好的人跟我對話
我最討厭邏輯不好的人跟我對話
我都不想聽
沒有邏輯的事情你不要跟我講話
好不好
聯發科評價
那個
要求不要完美點
看今天畫面有沒有再幫我調一下
調一下
我覺得不太行我覺得啦
好 車員
聯發科評價
麥格里證券喊3萬元給予優異大牌
2020年現在
這樣多少?一下子幾年?2020幾?
叫2020年
你明天
台灣股市會崩盤都不知道了
你怪我2020、20、20、麥格里證據
來來來
你不要說我私後
我郭總最討厭私後邊人家
我要是前面講在前面的
你看一下
你會發現我預言家
來
等一下
起始再一次
請那個威漢以後
因為今天是要請假
找微漢來 我們聯團隊隨便找一個
不是台大政大就是分析師
微漢也要當分析師 是帥哥喔
好不好 當然現在我這邊磨練
等到磨練成功後 我也不會說從我這邊磨練
不需要 成功不必在我
不過微漢記得一下
要播重播的時候 要多個前面幾秒
來 這個有時候我會跟他們講話
有時候跟你們講話
投資朋友我現在跟你們講話
看一下我那時候重播我怎麼罵
那些外資的邏輯很差
我說明年的行情都不知道
明年行情都不知道 你給我後年
來 看一下
所以你說賣隔離
各位講說 後年聯發科的TPU晶片
相關的一些營收 整個營收
可以從EPS5、60塊增加到EPS288有
我如果沒記錯的話 我聽到 把步啦
你看Google 錢麻煩就馬上把TPU晶片
都TPU晶片 是
這是聯發科最近的設計
我就不用COWAS了
你覺得後年一定會給聯發科嗎
不知道
不知道這是答案
不知道就不知道
不知為不知是不是
是不是 四肢也
不知道就不知道
專什麼知道
有些外資的邏輯都很錯誤
我問你 後年你知道
你明天怎麼走到路上會不會怎麼樣
我不是在罵你 我想試試
你看
怎麼用後年一撇史
你給我一萬塊的一次,什麼EPS多少錢?
用後年EPS,然後後年的本益比,亂七八糟
我看我AI不代表聯發科,一定會到一萬元
會不會?會,可是你不能用後年EPS來說
又不是TPU金面子為它生產而已
我們講,關這個邏輯,你是不是要看我一輩子?
廢話,你去問哪個外資,他們分析師
哪個外資分析師,像可以幹30年
可以像我在股市30年
不要說30年10年的外資分析就很厲害了
邏輯,不好意思,講到很嗆
請你告訴我邏輯還沒錯誤
重點是我事先預告
今天如果他沒有被搶單丟臉是我
所以你們不用擔心
我看今天網路上留言說
這時候阿宏海怎麼不講
你們有時候看很短嘛
宏海他就是EPS的20元
AI就是無緣佛界
等一下再跟你講莫德納做了什麼事情
你會發現起雞皮疙瘩
為什麼知道
因為AI的趨勢是對的
你看好連發科你不如看好記憶體
因為記憶體會確保好幾年
因為AI會越虛偶越大
你懂不懂
AI虛偶越大
我現在常常會連一些設計人員
機核人員
譬如說哇
這個一個報表做給我看
他們都做到生一個小時
我說你們都不用AI
我馬上生圖給你們看
三分鐘
我們不論你設計圖案我也是一樣
都兩分分鐘會用AI的人
比那些專業的人不會用AI的人
會搶100倍
真的真的真的我告訴大家
我現在超會找資料
因為我很喜歡問
而且我邏輯特好
我說真的不是我給你湊美
關聯8顆這個你不覺得
你就在看我節目一輩子嗎
隨便告訴你
你看到外資的報告
看到新聞好像很厲害
你賣隔離海1萬元的邏輯錯誤
2020年8年都不會被搶單
這獨佔了是不是
別人看我太封天 我叫他人看不穿
麥格里的你也不要難過
反正大家不知道你是誰
我說真的啦好不好
邏輯再訓練一下好不好
來
來我們來看一下
所有人看一下
我們來看一下大家給他打速
大家打速一下
含油沒有?我今天可以跟您講很多的股票
我股票很強,來我們看一下
能拿莫德納嗎?莫德納可以買喔
好高含,因為我,好不好
這則沒有開那麼短,對這則沒有那麼短
你不要開玩笑,好不好
沒有他是生病的,莉莉生病的
不過我說真的啦,我覺得重點還是在我身上
你有沒有發現到我現在主持人後來比例越來越低
越來越低
因為我覺得也不是每個人像我那樣工作款
我都不勉強別人
這跟大家講
來 正神秉還正神秉
確診的 COVID-19
其實我事前也有跟他講要去打疫苗
利用散半時間去打
可是他可能萬劑的沒有關係
講實在話這個都不能勉強大家
就像我跟你講
我已經跟你講了,10年內基本上你就會發現到
人們會開始平均稅數會從賣相100歲
10年後應該10年後,我們賣相100歲
會賣相100歲,我很多預告是很恐怖的
我很多預告是很恐怖,我為什麼說我很多預告很恐怖
今天就更恐怖的新聞來看一下
莫德納,等一下在講美國公司,這講美國公司的事情
莫德納疫苗大突破,威汗,帥哥以後拜託不要有黑的畫面,拉滿拉滿
我在跟我們訓練分析師跟大家講怎麼做節目
來,疫苗突破,爆展176%,怎麼樣爆展?
我直接做一個AI圖
AI圖不是請AI做一張圖沒那麼簡單
來
怎麼樣
診所有點錯字
診所mRNA的疫苗搭配Kichuda
這什麼意思
這另外一家的藥物
好像是莫沙東的
莫德納的疫苗配合人家的莫沙東的藥物
去黑色塑流
就是皮膚癌
皮膚癌 尤其是那種最毒的皮膚癌
最毒的皮膚癌
來 三期臨床 就是高風險的
三期臨床 基本上就是要拜拜了
反而怎麼樣 顯著降低手術後
移症復發率 沒有復發了 為什麼
來 你們要長命百歲 拜託 加油
加油 把身體養好 好不好 來
你看我是不是說 癌症最麻煩是
肺癌 我說肺癌很多種
或者是說很多你皮膚外有很多種
每個人種流都不太一樣 圖片都不太一樣
所以他個人他幫你個兒問的話
種流切除再幫你基因定序
你要知道你的種流是哪一種基因
基因定序又怎麼樣 AI篩選
你看我做這個圖非常漂亮
也是用AI做 但資料也是要問清楚
做完AI篩選預測以後
怎麼樣選出怎麼樣
從AI演算法的海量圖片數據中篩選
選出最34個關鍵圖片看圓
你知道為什麼嗎?
你像比如說那個HPV就是凡菜花的
有沒有?就是HPV疫苗又有4架的又有9架的
人家不會走一種
你懂不懂?好都是一樣
所以但那些都有點不太一樣
他選34個最關鍵的圖片看圓
選34個總會中一個吧
然後呢 編碼 mRNA 是新的技術
所以疫苗為什麼那麼快
那時候我說一年內就有疫苗
我就是看好 mRNA 我就看好 mRNA
我之前是他有醫生打掉來罵我
奇怪我只是要查的病 多年幹嘛罵我
他說要跟我姓 疫苗裡面有疫苗要跟我姓
後來不見了 好多罵我 不在乎
我再跟你講一件事喔
真的人的社會秘密十年過後
有機會賣相100歲
甚至五年過後開始賣相
你看疫苗製造 個人化的疫苗製造
挑選三十四個關鍵圖片有注射與T細胞訓練
我們自己的T細胞幫你殺
人類是最強的 你知道嗎
人家不知道為什麼要激鬥訓練
為什麼要怎麼樣 防吃呆 看腦
你就自己打疫苗是觸發你的T細胞
或者很多人你自己去殺那些病毒
T細胞 對你是T細胞有說
現在78有做什麼?連自己人都殺了
你怎麼知道?就要化兩樣 全部都一起殺了
T細胞精準辨識 清楚癌細胞
我只殺你這個圖片的 你這個癌症而已
效果奇好 那以後可以做什麼?
以後可以做很多的癌症 腎臟癌好像是腎臟癌
然後肺癌也有 現在已經做二期去的 現在三期去的
MRNA還有什麼三中因子
那你變年輕了
這些都是AI的數據
以前會跑那麼快嗎?
沒有
我問你一件事情
你有巴菲特假設你有巴菲特
你現在九十幾歲你有一兆資產
跟我現在二十五歲我十萬塊
你要跟巴菲特交換身體嗎?
不要
我管你有沒有一兆資產?
沒錯吧
當然不要
快死了
我很崇拜他
我當然不希望他快死
你不會換
八飛帶也想跟你換 那你不會換
所以對八飛帶來講 他要一照又怎麼樣
我0 因為我花個1000億 我投資AI
如果能讓我長命百歲
那些有錢人想法都是一樣的
秦始皇為什麼跑去東營
為什麼 叫徐福去東營
有此一說 產生不老的
為什麼 有錢有事之後就產生不老
所以AI告訴你現在已經是真的開始了
今天這些東西 莫德納一天長170%
你們看拍到一天一天斬一罩
這是真的題材 活生生的AI進步在前面
你們只看到小鼻子小眼睛
他愛我 他不愛我
我的背鬥元件為什麼疊個兩塊三塊
I don't care 你看短的不要跟我來
我看長的你知道 我喜歡談預約家
我很不眩那些老頭顧分析師
我每天賺多少 我每天賺多少
我摸頭跟顧老師不一樣
我來跟你講這些東西的
我享受的是那種預言家
男女朋友
你真的跟家不一樣
很爽你知道嗎
雖然講話這樣出俗 很爽
你看不懂我的瑞士 我看
那節目實在太無聊了
有時候真的好大聲
那時候是表演
有時候只是要讓你記得這些東西
我再講一件事
來 我再給你第二個預測
10年內
這是預測 不代表百分之百
好不好
我們這分析師沒有百分之百
我先跟你講
你要有百分之百你去找別人
我不做這個事情
主管機關也規定我們不能這樣講
可是我告訴你我覺得有極大機率十年內
但是他講的是績效
可是我連你看醫療保健我都跟你
都很讚跟你講
所有風險我都跟你講
十年內
我跟你講 你們記得黨務存
這樣黨務存的藥物
或者是PASCK9
就這樣黨務存的藥物
會變成日常生活
所需的必需品質 什麼意思
越來越多的學說 越來越多的研究告訴你
膽固醇是這樣子 你能的扣打
就是額度這麼高 你一開始可能出生的時候對不對
你第一病毒膽固醇如果是100以上
你就會增加很快 增加到這邊你會爆掉
你人生就是心血管 疾病就中風了
在這邊就心機葛聖 拜拜
腦中風就拜拜 心血管主色
中風在主色在新戰就新疆管主色
就是腦中就是就是就是新戰中風
好不好 新戰病
這邊腦血管中風
就可能眼睛或怎麼樣
這樣怎麼懂
好 膽固醇 低密度膽固醇
累積累積到這邊就爆炸
你知道我意思嗎
所以越低越好
以後一定有這種人的額度就大概這樣子
對
OK嗎
對 怎麼意思
增加到一體的程度
假設你低密度短過程200以上
不好意思 你可能增加速度很快
你可能30幾歲的中風 拜拜
如果你低密度短過程150
你可能是50歲
一增加的話
你增加比一半人快
你150比200都比人家快
這200多塊
你可能是30
你可能是50歲中風
200的低密度短過程200的
你可能30幾歲中風
低密度短過程100以下的
甚至50以下 你增加很慢
就算到100歲你到這邊會贏
還沒到警戒點
到底你怎麼就爆炸了?
我這個你第二個預告
相信我啦
可是你要產命百歲有癌症對不對?
前提是三高二次
彈尿病、高血壓
好什麼?
還有膽固醇我跟你講是不是?
好不好?
彈尿病、膽固醇、膽固醇
減肥症該打就打
好不好?
因為減重後這三個都會下來
很多問題是減重
好不好?
減重、睡眠、運動
那基本上你們就產命百歲了
好不好?
然後不要再金錢煩惱,就殘民百歲
要把生命變寬
懂不懂?
反正用什麼說?不要死
所以不要玩太刺激的
我也是覺得不要滑雪
你們喜歡滑,我也沒辦法
我已經告訴你,你長民百歲了
以後你們先學我,你們相信我,我會講預言家
我跟你講,這些東西我都預告
好不好?OK嗎?
我告訴你,講那健康題材會收會員嗎?
沒有,收不到會員
我不在乎,我開心
我跟你講,你看很多健康頻道
說不定還沒有我深入顯出來 我告訴你
我騙你啦
我已經跟你講
哪有人一直跟你講說會產命白歲的
AI
我是第一個看到確的確BT
我知道台灣股市要噴出去的安然
你可以來跟別人跟我PK
是不是
好不好
真的啦好不好
直播95歲好不好
財經系能賭嗎
積古標有天分 你們不要問我
對啊
我
可以先研發出不會突頭的疫苗
我也希望我很怕我哪天不能翹了
這個沒有噴喔 好不好
既然打過泥去哪裡買 我不是醫生 你去問醫生
藥局其實都有賣啦 可是先給醫生看 好不好
小心等一通 換一隻少一隻 不會嘛 再買就好
AI功課疫苗 折折寶貝明天會噴嗎
你們不要看那麼短 好不好
來 折寶貝好多人問年電
你們都喜歡叫我們寶貝 好看一下
年電沒怎麼樣啊,這邊都打第二隻腳,我想這邊股票很好,
我跟你講勇者就是我在這邊買最低檔,
這天不是我,很多股票那天嘛,7月底的時候,7月29號30號那附近嘛,
買111的2050嘛,勇者是我,這個是屬屬的練過,不要血一半人做不到,
厲害的人在這邊買、聰明的人在這邊買、或是這邊買
你懂了嗎?都一樣差不多
懂不懂?打第二隻腳確定打第二腳成功
或者反覆之後再確定打打底成功對不對?
不會破底
或是第二隻腳要下去的時候這邊買
懂不懂?現在這邊就可以買了
好不好?
台灣國…你們還聽不懂我剛才講的那些東西
我連…你們都聽不懂我還可以解釋
我連麥格里證券寫的報告還1萬
他不是不能喊,他的邏輯有錯誤
我直接告訴他邏輯有錯誤
我說隨時會被搶單
不到一兩個月就被搶單了
這是我最恐怖的地方
這個很難預測
我都可以預測成功
台灣股市要到十萬點是非常好預測
因為隨著時間發展
其實通貨膨脹
隨著每家公司的EPS
平均EPS會增加
台灣股市十萬點是市債必行
只是問好如何怎麼去做而已
五年內很保守
四年內我已經說得很保守
我跟你講那是因為我是公開媒體分析師
我告訴你因為我是台灣最好的分析師
我跟你講四年內甚至可能三年內都有可能我們騙你
三年內十萬點你為什麼要小鼻子小眼睛
問我今天這些東西呢
不需要我講都是稀優概念股
懂我在說什麼嗎
連這麼難預測的
還有我告訴你AI會讓人家長命百歲
真的有了
你們去問所有的醫界人員
如果真的喜歡做研究的
個人化的疫苗這麼厲害
那是一個新的發展
那是一個很恐怖的發展你知道嗎
這有些做研究的醫生
你們拜託你們醫學人員
拜託醫務人員
拜託去看我剛講的那些東西好不好
你們也回答一下
這是非常恐怖的進步
你們就知道我差多少
跟別人差多少
這不是我的專產
我只喜歡預測未來
所以這些不是我專產的醫療
或者外資賣隔離
你可以邏輯業內會不會被搶單
我不用去問聯發科的高層經理副總
你們會不會被搶單 他們自己不知道
可是我可以說他們有可能被搶單
那TPU金面有沒有很難做
旁觀者清 色系才最難預測的
我都預測成功了
你不要跟我小比小姐講這些
就是為5萬點
應該說應該就是為5萬點
加個應該
遲早的 今年真的會
好不好 遲早的 好不好
一切一切遇到前面
我也可以 美女跟妳講專討氣
3374 妳不要我像老頭顧
跟妳講的東西 OK
我順便喝個水 好不好
講機校 機校今年機校很厲害
來 1 1 好不好
1 1動能的 1 1 幫我
講一下這個簡訊 來
我們今天恭喜你
精采一天開盤的簡訊就暫停了 來
好 8月20號 禮拜四
今天的簡訊
恭喜3374 精采股價開高噴出
一開盤就鎖上漲停
我們買進到現在
最高已經大賺69%
我持續看好他
手上吃果獲利續報
恭喜大家賺大錢啦
那那那那那錢
那那那錢 所以OK
來
暫停
暫停再暫停啦
是不是
等會我還說什麼
不覺得節目很精彩嗎
欸
醫療的那些
你們想到有個分屍體
我跟你講你們有機會陳病百歲
不覺得很開心嗎?把三高字為什麼?
你不能走 不然談到病截肢了
你說腿還可以展出來吧?
是不是?OK嗎?來
護士都變機器人 這我不知道
來 買國具
我不信十萬點 你不信
來說我最想粉絲
我看十萬點
遲早的事好不好?
何時而已?怎麼會不是?
你連如果十萬點都不懂
你就不知道什麼叫通貨膨脹
合時而已,OK嗎?
遲早是合時而已,那10萬點不在版,你一定會賺錢
最後兩碼的事情
一堆自己的玩具不要一直說好話
這些都是我真的不好意思
這個不是玩具,我能買到140萬,那我也真的很有錢
本來就有錢,花這種錢,其實都不用跟一些人廢話
直接封鎖它就好
他們都說你們是網軍
紀錄者則、討厭者則直接跟我對做
像男人一般一樣好不好
OK
原則聽的不會一直在那邊打字的
這什麼我不懂
不要管 別管這些
來 聽到噴出四粉絲好嗎
來來 不要
你們竟然跳好快
凱果準備串心膏 來來
分享韓運的看法
我的重點還是AI
好運股像跟AI醜不上邊
AI知道嗎
不想看就走對沒錯啦
不想看就走
不要浪費時間
我不是財經過
我不是其他網紅
我不是要靠爭論來的
就是準不準可以不要廢話那麼多
不喜歡就對著就好了
趕快離開我市場
趕快離開我的頻道
紅到直播的時候越來越多傳媒
真的好多人
我說過中美金兩百元
現在都很委屈
現在一堆股票委屈
你們進來到時候你們就說
這時候你好厲害
我關我
你不要管我你不厲害
我本來就厲害 你真的不要管我 你不用管我生死
拜託 你們賺錢好不好 你們賺錢比我賺錢還重要
真的 我沒有很在乎錢
我已經告訴我人生就是要去22台 會去5車了
我現在慢慢的 慢慢的 慢慢的 慢慢的在賣相了
已經要賣相第三台了 是不是
因為我在4萬年買 很漂亮 39000年買
好不好 這跟大家講 好不好 OK嗎
以AI幫你開窮 這我不知道
我不知道事情我不知道 不跟你講 好不好
來 有沒有莫德納相當類國 台灣的莫德納
台灣的生技股都是籌碼戰而已
所以為什麼不講台灣的生技股
那是看公司派高層要不要拉
公司派主力要不要拉而已
基本上我不買好不好
來
有排分析師
我不當分析師我看應該300萬吧
訂閱吧
因為就不會有很多限制了
但我覺得被限制也沒什麼不好
被規定也沒什麼不好
來
來來來 我加入會員有賺錢 那應該之前加入
最近會員普普同倫真的不好意思 我都講話很實在
好不好 習慣帥哥者的自信 詐騙集團的績效都沒力了
詐騙集團的績效是假的 好不好
就些老頭顧一樣 我每天講賺錢 到底有沒有買
沒買 好不好 來 我真的分析資源基本
資源我是賭以後的ASIC 這個有點到AI的誤會
說股價比較差,真的不好意思,我比較少講資源資源
那時候看他現金很漂亮
可是不代表他會死,因為他沒展
就不追高嘛,你懂不懂
不追高,好不好,OK
我是折磅完全
活那麼久沒錢會很可憐
賺錢比較實在,好不好
還是要強調一隻
整個是連續三年都相對低一點
然後跌崩盤四、五千點在附近的時候
幾千萬甚至雜一億的男人
連續三年都在相對的地點很漂亮
這個都是有新聞可考 有節目可以看的
你還覺得我是一般人 你實在太遜了
還有我剛才講這個東西
沒想到大安博學很厲害
就是那個TPU晶片那個麥格里的邏輯是錯誤
還是你們覺得這個預測很強
預測對了很正常
去年拉一下 去年是早就噴出去的
好不好 這跟大家講 好不好 來來
看大家有沒有回應 看一下大家有沒有回應
好像現在大家 我要變速讀 你知道
澤爾斯檢頭法 是啊 他有人說我戴假髮
他講假髮本來不會是短髮啦
有這種假髮嗎 有這麼速起來假髮嗎 沒有啦
來來 澤爾保軍 好啦 我們不要去
也 那個些人 對啦
謝謝你們一直罵那些無聊人的
可是不要理他們 直接封鎖就好
我剛把聯電換成兩久金,環球金不錯啦
環球金是不是昨天,我看環球金可以線是吧
前幾天暫停又殺下去,昨天變跌
你不覺得環球金跟精彩,這阻力還是都有看我節目我不知道
我們是震盪洗盤的你知道嗎,開高走低拉起來
環球金一樣一千元以上就是不會啦
買啦真的啦好不好
到時候細菌會很缺
好不好?這時候你的花呢?
就那花先結過了好不好?
來,這時候會扣分嗎?
你說我們講過,我被扣分喔?
我可能有講過,可能沒講過
你真的醫學常常是
好,來,大概兩三千元你講說看好不好?
想請問腦癌要怎麼看?
來啦,紅癌也是會20塊啦
紅癌是20塊啦好不好?
還是有機會20塊
20塊 現在很多人是不相信變現
來 莫德納給我非常大的信心
證明AI真的可以產品百歲
AI可以影響以後你的製程
你們說工業所有的東西
你知道基本上我現在什麼事情我都會AI
我很多人叫我們公司行政或一些研究員做事情
有時候看不下去我就去做好賣
我做都比他們快
我直接問 因為我會問你知道嗎
真的我跟你講會用AI的人真的是以一擋百
我騙你 這是以一擋百
現在我跟你講八卦 現在確GPT比GPT強很多
就是確GPT比Google的GPT強很多
所以會增差很多 確GPT自力大增
哪個分析是不是跟你講這東西
沒有啦 比一下投股很多更不會用
他們更不會用 幫我解隔盤
我幫我怎麼樣 或怎樣
我幫我選個標股
他們都是最出錢的
他們不知道那個差別
只有我知道 因為我每天在比較
你懂不懂 我每天在去看
問問題 你懂不懂
因為你把紅海丟了,如果以波動性來講,
長得快慢而已的話,那你可以把它換掉,
你可以把它換掉你知道嗎?
好不好?
則太紅的小英被針對,常常被針對啦,
沒關係啦,我覺得我這個到處到之前,
我沒有刻意對不起會研究,
我是分析師,我投資顧問啊,
有賺有賠啊,
我不會去跟你說跟主離配,我不去做這種事情,
而且我選到大量的股票啊,
是不是?自由的罵欣欣被別的分析是影響
你看被影響你是有可能賣70塊,現在1000多
哇!100多塊抵到70塊,覺得我是混蛋,誰是混蛋
那些影響你的分析才是最過分的,不是嗎?
不是嗎?是不是?
你看那個其他分析師本來有些要跟我和解,有一個不跟我和解的
跟我和解我就沒事,我也不想,我其實說我人很好
不跟我和解的,搞到最後連律師費都省
要告我親自出庭 親自出庭
然後連個律師都不請 省錢省得這樣子
我才不管他 我就是律師非我造花
我就這種人 然後搞到自己身體不好
你們都知道誰啊 是不是某一位信章的分析師啊
搞到自己不好 我也覺得難過你會逼呢
因為你抽得到的就覺得郭忠是卵嗜子
我就不試著這樣去打聽 你就不理我
是不是 很氣的 這很氣的
我那時候打開手機都一堆回報我的文章
你也算是這樣子 搞業績也不好 身體也不好 還是祝福他
成員了 成員了 來
帥哥哲我結婚 你結婚只聽老婆 現在只聽你的 準備離婚
你們不要這樣子 我們可以一起生活
來 不要亂換骨 台獨我不講政治
為什麼 為什麼人們是不是喜歡立即定義 紅外轉國際
我覺得紅外轉國際姿勢不錯
富貴險中求啦 別的東西到時候還是會缺
只是會不會缺那麼多
沒有 我告訴你 1200的國距我不敢
我不敢想 800的國距我覺得有機會
好不好 這就殺下去
華興哥好不容易殺下去 我覺得OK
不要追漲 昨天華興哥看來一副要斬田 一定要殺下去
今天就可以 明天就可以考慮買了
我跟你講 這根本沒有反彈多少
彈個30% 20% 可以買 可以買 真的
沒有那麼差啦
沒有那麼差啦 自然殺龍枝 殺楚自古嘛 是不是
莫德納這一個東西讓我對AI更有信心
以後會是AI醫療
你說 對對對對 你要我說
我覺得你們可以買那個 譬如說美國生技ETF
如果你們要賭的話 我覺得美國生技ETF可以賭
來來來 不講了 我自己想去買
我去買一下美國生技ETF
台灣有美國生技ETF嗎
就直接買美國的生技股,不要買台灣的生技ETF
因為台灣的生技股可能會一起拉
對,以後開始會炒美國的生技ETF
因為會不止莫德納或很多公司開始埃政制好了
之前的時候會有很多公司開始埃政可以制好了
我跟你講這三到五年內會很多
那都是AI造成的
記住我講的事情是美國生技ETF
你就不要壓打一個家公司
為什麼?因為ETF的好處就是這家公司拜拜了
還可以買別家公司 你懂不懂?
這就是為什麼我推薦台灣50勝過推薦台積電
我對你們很好 台積電應該一例不妖
但是BUT成了有BUT怎麼辦?
有BUT怎麼辦?
對我BUT是怎麼辦?
台積電不行怎麼辦?
你要別的股票 所以買台灣50比較好
我都是風險百第一 沒有人像我這樣子
你買台灣50 說到會員 不行
整個怎麼看AI跟私募基金的錢會不會爆掉引發金融海報?
問題還是回到,你們還是聽不懂嗎?
AI跟私募基金的錢或者現在瓦發型投資型公司在,
它不是發型投資型公司在嗎?
利率變很高,然後造成美國公司在值率也高嗎?
美國公司在值率很高,那是不是吸引股市資金?
造成自己連股市的崩盤,前幾年股市崩盤?
那動點回來了,AI可不可以賺錢?
我就回答你的問題啦
我生氣果就想投資了
我是8倍的
如果真的可以確定我成名百歲
為什麼不能丟個100億
那些有錢的很多
你知道現在的問題是
我記得其實我好像90%幾的資產
全世界80%90%幾的資產
我聽到之前有一個研究
距在1%的人身上
那些有錢的願意把錢套出來就不一樣
那麼多,OK嗎?
這時候我傳染看你的台,這哪一台的
你不要猜我的台好不好
全部20年了,怎麼樣?
怎麼樣?OK
只要堪配完全就是主力要不要拉
我不想這麼裹票,不好意思
而且這邊主力很厲害,一直猜一直猜
問完遊戲,講多了不要得罪
好不好
有時候講話已經很實在,我不要一直得罪人
我不認識別家頭顧爺爺了
你們不要攻擊這個畫面
聽好,你們不要攻擊這個
我也不會怎麼樣 我也不會攻擊你
你一直要攻擊我 我冷冷 攻擊太過分
一定回擊 回擊到你覺得很煩
好不好 OK
但你也不會故意再主動攻擊
可是回擊到 一定會覺得
真的不要對哲哲做這種事 真的好不好
OK 所以我不想講康佩特說壞話
我只能說那邊 這裡面的主力
不是我所能了解的 那我就不碰他
就這樣 OK
來
來來
microfairway 為什麼要反而做
有些人就無力 我有些人就喜歡做空
每個人個性不同
這時候愛你 請問尾串還會長嗎
你們都這樣子跟我撒嬌
justing 你是男生
尾串也很長 看一下
尾串也有機會
其實這幾天尾串
這現在的現行裡面是尾串最漂亮
我們看抽獻毒
對阿 尾串還突破力性高
是不是?對啊
所以尾串的現形其實突然間拉起來
尾串很漂亮
你現在如果用看現形的話
鴻海的線圖比尾串醜很多
三支裡面
三支預算票怎麼辦
這個顯得出我的年紀了
扯遠
三支老AI裡面
鴻海管達尾串
尾串現在現形最漂亮
來 關答 25是聯發科 你注意這樣子
今天這個是很大的一空
所以我本來想買它 我現在想想算了
沒想到聯發科的轉型的TPU晶片
很容易被人家取代
我跟你講 那我問一件事
這些外資分析師拿一個在1430元
1430元那附近我是叫你紅海換台積電
台積電萬年發科有沒有,回答有,我在跟你們解盤
1400多1500元的時候有沒有,
這些外資分其實等到4970的時候,
才跟你講看我年發科是幹嘛,
為什麼不賺這一段,
你看我為什麼我就喜歡買低機器,
你們現在好像國際我就喜歡買它,
大不了少賺一點,
連南亞科我就賣掉它,
反正我賺錢大不了少賺一點,
我不在乎啊,
是不是今天要有人新聞出來
我就說最近為什麼
你看趙建民也好,九妹也好出事
你那對方新聞區的,錢也委屈的
你那覺得兩才兩失
你新聞區就算你錢也委屈
如果你分手的時候
你就說我給你一個兩百萬
我給你一個三百萬,對不起你
正常人也不會報你料
是不是,趙建民來,我給你一千萬
陳迅給你一千萬
是不是,負責其他
不行,我分期付款,人家是不是覺得你誠意
調車到我為什麼沒事
但是錢給的多,心裡有沒有委屈?可能委屈錢給的多,就是這麼簡單
所以我告訴你,股票也是一樣,留點錢給人家賺嘛
我沒有賣4970,我賣4000塊以上,可以嗎?可以
留點錢給他賺嘛,我沒差,你就低機器人家不要的時候我撿起來嘛
人氣我取,人氣我取,人氣真的不要取,不然會出事
人氣我取,人家不要的我一樣
聯發科這東西你就覺得,但我看一下有沒有說有
來來來,有你看有,怎麼那麼少
一個兩個三個有啦,有啦,三個有沒有
三千才買的有沒有,有你看都有講
都有講1400多的時候有講
不然叫台積電換成聯發科
是不是
資金不多啊,是不是中美金貨獎金選一個就好
就選環球金好了好不好
對不對,好不好
你們不要那麼多壓細金
壓個30%就好了好不好
群聯為什麼一直開高走低
我不知道市場好像不太喜歡他們老闆一直講話是不是
怎麼樣我不知道 有有
怎麼看貝森特舊美在 來來來
貝森特舊美在 我不要給你重播 來來
我先跟你講
講的你又起雞皮疙瘩
我昨天這張圖你有沒有印象
我說你不要拿2007年比
2007年看起來好像都是
2007年的美在直率都是5.3下
2007年青東海峽從9300年9點跌到3955點
從2008年的5月20號9309點
跌到2008年11月21號的3955點
如屬家增 因為那時候我很痛苦
來
這跟大家講
也謝謝那一家公司
那時候那蔡兩分的意思不給我機會
還有我現在越來越強大
真的是 真的
不夠機會就file著車
我很謝謝他
我不是酸啦 我是真的啦
反而讓我覺得人生命很短
你知道嗎
那段時間反而自己做股票還賺比較多
來 休息一陣子了沒 休息很長
30年期美債直立 我扯遠了
金融海峽那時候不是很遠嗎
很慘嗎
那時候美債是美債直立率
這是費的利率
你看 那時候美債直立率是怎麼那麼高
因為不得不高
因為我基準的利率
費的利率就那麼高
我不可能比他少
我比他少誰要買我
費的利率就在
我就去存定存就好
我幹嘛買美債
所以費的利率就
費的利率就那麼高
我每天在直率高
我每天在直率利率要更高一點點
很正常
可是現在我費的利率怎麼樣
3.63
這麼低
我每天在直率這麼高
我說這兩個不一樣
你知道為什麼這兩個不一樣
今天答案
為什麼這兩個不一樣
一一不同
我昨天忘記舉例子那種時候,這兩個不一樣為什麼一不同
這時候你站起來有道理,可是又沒道理
以前重點是每載子率都是5.3都會影響資金
你不要硬扯什麼費得利率是一個5.25,一個現在是3.63
重點是每載子率都是5.3,那資金會吸引過去
然後重新定價,你看很多網紅可以講重新定價
然後資金被吸走,你有講
為什麼費得利率以前差距不大,現在差距很大,
代表跌就補沒問題,來答案出來了,今天做什麼事?
他買了40億元美債,然後告訴你邏輯,
聽懂了你就會變聰明,你會覺得我很聰明,
我問你一件事,他買了41億美債,
買長期的賣短期的,我買了以後是不是,
我跟妳講過,直率率跟債券價格是不是相反?
我把它買了以後對不對?
是不是價格往上?
我一直買它嘛,美國才真的不,我就是買啊
我買了美國債券,我一直買把它價格拱上去
債券直率是不是下滑?資金成本是不是下滑了?
沒有5.3了,可能到5.1了
這個時候是不是股市的資金就會進來了?
我那時候是美債直率一直很高啊
我現在利用我一直收購,把美債直率價格下滑
把他每在直率給打下去
把價格往上提高 把整個人在直率下滑
我那時候說每在直率不能再高
把他打下去了
對不對 他做這件事情
好 聽我講
來喔 在聽這段
你會覺得很恐怖喔 講在前面
你覺得如果是2007年的時候對不對
這2007年 對
用這一招有辦法嗎
這邊是美在 這邊是直率有辦法
打不下去 為什麼打不下去
你怎麼?我怎麼打?我每再值率就是要比費德利率高
我打不下去,我打到5.1幹嘛?
那時候費德利率那麼高,我去存定存就好了
為什麼說現在跟以前不一樣?
因為以前差距不大,每再值率是5.29
費德利率,這些定存的利率基準就是5.25
兩個差距不大,我就算現在要把它值率打下去
每再值率打下去頂多打到5.25附近
差不多了,打不下去了
可是我現在費的利率定程利率可能就這邊附近
5.3%應該要3.63% 有差了1.7%
我可以把它打下去
我用買的就可以把它打下去
以前差距不多
我的基準的這邊你只能比我高
你不能比我高我去換定程就好了
現在差那麼多 所以可以打得下去
懂不懂 有沒有分析師可以講這個
沒有 他們不懂 我這不知道錯畢
這個總體看起來是網紅,背著東西
有什麼財經的東西?
有沒有分析式肯解決斷?
一個都沒有,這一段很精采
財經相關是佩服者之
有沒有聽到?
聽到按個讚吧
好不好?
他一點氣可以玩,對沒有錯
懂不懂?
變聰明的聽懂,他打下去他們懂了
變聰明了你們已經比人都
我看我看什麼節目 看我節目
我雖然節目有時候30%在臭屁自己
70%我跟你講沒有別的節目跟你講這些東西
學到是不是
提前分析我們到
現在你很強 你都買
總體經濟學的觀念很強
謝謝大家
內容顯示你一樣的真的懂我的人
就知道我很猛
上面一大大說我感覺主力有跟整個股票對準
你要我說實話嗎
去年我覺得比較有主力過對準
今年沒有 今年還好
他們可能後來發現很多的法案
很多的那個訴訟案件後發現
我是清白的
我真的不會跟其他主力配合
可能大家覺得比較喜歡我股票
去年感覺好像有人一直跟我對準股票
今年我覺得還好啦
還好啦 還好 真的還好
真的還好,金融反而覺得很多人幫我拉股票,謝謝他們
金融學到的東西,概念很重要,聽不懂沒關係
就是反正有很多空間可以把資訊打下去
好不好,阿翔幾分了
然後我們來講股票了
全年剛才有講中美金跟很有金
來來來,兩個都可以買啦
OK嗎,好不好
我要喜歡環球金,你一直要買低價股
你就買中美金吧,好不好
知道都會拉起來了好不好
我認為知道都會拉起來好不好
我們節目很專業
真的我今天講很多
你看預告啊
那個我告訴你賣隔離邏輯出
我還提早預告今天驗證
然後為什麼可以人類可以利用AI藏命百歲
我會深入潛出
第三個
為什麼同樣都是5.3%的
美國30年期公開子綠魚
為什麼這一次跟2007年不一樣
你拿2007年會崩盤
所以現在會崩盤
出戶差很多
因為基準利率不一樣
基人力也不一樣,差別差很多,所以它有空間打下去
有1.7%的空間打下去
有可能這邊講一個嗎?
他們都看新聞,哇影響到了
說What?為什麼?
為什麼可以輕鬆影響到?
這個真的很恐怖喔,這東西
我自己覺得很屌啦,我不知道你覺得有沒有覺得
真的真的,好不好?
最近跟我覺得太無聊,因為最近太多專業你知道嗎?
我比較喜歡搞笑啦
給責愛你一次的機會,這你們好像比較記得
比較喜歡,每天沒有那麼多梗啦
其實我已經蠻多梗啦
今天總經很多東西啦
他什麼東西要講
雜訊科群聯F
我們看一下差不多啦
剛剛有人說資源
資源就先要死不活啦好不好
他也跌不下去
因為之前也沒有漲很多
我都選都沒有漲很多的股票
都漲差不多了
國劇被動元件我覺得不錯啦
我會來救他們啦
好不好
遲早會拉起來的啦
台灣50,0050拉回來是可以買嘛
我們還是賺1000多萬嘛是不是
1200還是1300我不知道
好不好 這跟大家講還是1000一
反正有賺錢就對了 應該要賺1000萬
我們看一下精彩 精彩這個就是感覺
精彩裡面的大戶是真的滿那個
就是 我不知道為什麼要完成這樣子
這樣子人家不太敢追 我不知道他們看我的節目
我覺得要鎖展庭就鎖展庭 不要好像做價差
可是看得出來它就是最後要拉起來
近台從來已經被人家鎖定了
你們應該至少裡面的一個大戶就是要鎖定它
我就至少會上去 我認為
這些股票你不要單一重壓股票
不要單一重壓的話 基本上我的股票
我認為很多股票大多數都會上去
好不好 我愛你們 沒問題 沒問題結束了
則是國保 謝謝大家
台股參加要不要變少影響
當然變少影響 很多股票很難拉起來
好吧,來來,年夜可以買嗎?
那種CPU的題材我覺得有點,
我覺得有點那是中時無到要不要拉啦,
跟那些生機股也是一樣,
沒有內心消息怎麼買啊,我又沒內心消息,
我每次在節目上說我不跟主力票,
你覺得那些主力會來找我嗎?
好不好,我鄭教授那個法院黃永公到,
不起訴 不是不起訴
今天你知道有個人罵那個告羅志仙
說羅志仙A他的錢 就是幫他刷卡
幫他刷卡你知道嗎
然後檢察官還不起訴說
就類似說他不明其妙
就某個人覺得被盜刷是
幹嘛硬要刷我信用卡
覺得是統一集團害的害他
檢察官還是給他不起訴
他不起訴說
那是一個檢察官的做事
別人搞個自救會 搞一群人告國者
所以我跟主力配合 還去證家所調資料
還配動用關係 警政署搞成動用關係
那個分析師我是在幹什麼
結果國總不是不起訴而已 直接牽結
兩個警察官覺得都沒事
連不起訴都不用寫 根本就是無理群 看到不到
OK嗎 這誠信真的是 其實他們幫我打廣告
莫名其妙提告還有不起訴書
我連不起訴書都不用了
都不用寫了
完全就是覺得莫名其妙
懂不懂
來
先跟大家世界重點上去
來看一下世界好不好
現在多少47
我今天好含有流汗
結束 愛你們
今天愛你們
台正哥
台正哥一樣好不好
台正哥一樣一起看好不好
你不要看
不要每天一天跌就好
台正哥因為我很少人買
我就不講這個東西了好不好
不需要把重心發生
今天直播人數7000多人
今天很多東西
我講AI的這個長壽跟莫德納疫苗
祝他產品百歲 接近看看
真的我愛你們
真的我希望你們開心
還有跟公仔那種總體經濟
你記得一件事好不好
為什麼跟2007年差很多
我這個很精采
你就知道我跟其他分析是差的
為什麼差很多
去想想看兩者的分析師
對股票再回測
是不是要回測第二隻腳
那不重要 有回測就要買
所以歡迎人家去下旬
零八零六八零八五
後價來私訊我
說實實的我要查會員
我捷徑我所能
不論對我錯
我一切一切預告在前面
我也捷徑我所能來
盡最大努力來幫你賺大錢
我愛你們 拜拜
自然因獨立判斷
省省評估
並自負投資風險